did Donald Trump ever really want to be
President my theory for a while has been
that Donald Trump sort of overestimated
the intelligence of Republican primary
voters he thought I'll run it'll be
publicity but these these people are
actually going to select me as their
nominee because I don't know anything
and clearly I have no business being
president of the United States but he
ended up winning the primary and
realized I can't just back out now that
would be really bad so what really is
going on in Donald Trump's head right
now just days before this election will
Gabriel Sherman who has done some great
reporting I was given access by Trump
campaign manager Kellyanne Conway to the
Trump campaign during recent days
there's a fascinating article in New
York magazine which I would encourage
you to read in total but the most
shocking part of it is a portion where
Kellyanne Conway explains that Trump is
totally indifferent about whether he
wins or not and Kellyanne actually had
to explain to trump listen you have to
try to win because people are working
for you people have donated to you the
Republican Party has elected you you
can't just bail and she actually said to
Gabriel Sherman that she got really mad
at Trump because he revealed that he's
essentially indifferent to the election
results I'll put a quote up for you from
this article where Kellyanne Conway says
he said I think will win and if not
that's okay too and I said it's not okay
you can't say that your dry cleaning
bill is like the annual salaries of the
people who came to your rallies and they
believe in you and this isn't even that
new because in August even Trump himself
told CNBC if at the end of 90 days I
fallen short it's okay I go back to a
very good way of life of life at the end
it's either going to work or I'm going
to you know going to have a very nice
long vacation and Kellyanne Conway told
Gabriel Sherman that she had to confront
Trump and say you know you can't talk
about a really nice long vacation
because you don't care if you win this
is in a way the opposite of Mitt Romney
in in his final days where we saw
through that documentary MIT which is
Netflix is fantastic he wanted it and he
really thought he was going to win and
with Trump it seems like he kind of
realizes the odds are not in his favor
and he seems absolutely and totally
neutral about whether hey I'll be the
next president of the US or I won't kind
of all the same to me and I don't think
he expected to do so well from the
beginning I think it just kind of caught
on and he maybe he didn't want to do the
work at first but then he realized well
I can give out the responsibilities to
Mike Pence and other people and I can
just be kind of be like a figurehead
president yeah yeah but first of all
she's a great motivational speaker I
think that she should probably
transition to doing that for a living
but I think there's a few things here I
think one of the reasons maybe he's
saying oh I don't care if I win or not
out I'll take a vacation is he's not in
politics I feel like if you have a stake
in politics then you will definitely
kind of have a different opinion about
the outcome and maybe care more if you
lose or win and another thing that I
just was thinking about is I'm wondering
this is kind of confirming the the
Michael Moore conspiracy theory about
this is just he wanted a higher
negotiating power because he was upset
with his NBC deal I'm wondering if this
is true well I think what Trump is
realizing one way or the other is that
the president has lots of power and
Donald Trump is very hungry for power
but when you're the president it's not
completely unchecked absolute power the
way it is when you're the CEO right you
can decide you're the decider is the
president about Vladimir Putin or letter
important you're the decider if you're
president of the US within relatively
narrowly established bounds and at
decisions that are sort of okayed and
approved and laid out for you by huge
teams of people in the judiciary and all
of these other forms of apparatus
apparatus that exist so I think that
Trump is very power hungry but maybe
he's realizing Pat that the type of
power you get as president is not like
being CEO of the Donald J Trump
foundation and I don't think he even
realizes that and that's why we often
criticize him him for having some
fascistic qualities right i I'm I'm sure
he's okay with not being president I did
I just don't think he wants to lose so
publicly I think we'll the one thing I
think that there are some Trump
supporters Rachel who will see this and
they'll say I like the fact that he
doesn't really
care that much about whether he wins or
not I like the fact that he doesn't even
really uh understand what exactly the
president can and can't do because he's
an outsider and he'll come in like an
outsider as if that's some objectively
good thing yeah that's a good point I'm
also kind of wondering now he would
rather drop out or lose on his own terms
yes something I've thought about know
that I mean that III think that this has
not been good for Trump in a lot of ways
but trump hotel bookings are really
suffering this can't be good for his
kids right 16-17 sexual assault
allegations against their dad this can't
be good for the relationship with
melania right i mean i know that she
said hey you know I believe he's
apologized and I've accepted the apology
I don't think that this has been
particularly good for Trump Pat right
it's kinda too late to get out now right
there's a week left in the election
there there was plenty of chances for
him to get out with a certain golden
parachute and I think he just denied and
didn't accept any of those possibilities
well maybe maybe now he's learning how
passing laws works in Congress he's
getting more of a sense that things
don't just automatically happen in
politics when you're president of the
United States let's take a break i'm on
twitter it d pakman we'll be back after
this we've had as a sponsor this week
betty si.com we're at you know it's not
like one of these just online sports
betting sites where you're betting on
the line for an NFL game you can do that
but they're actually doing election odds
and election bets and people have been
emailing me saying David uh I'm thrilled
that you have bet dsi as a sponsor and I
use the coupon code Pakman 25 because
it's so obvious what's going to happen
on november eighth and i'm gonna make a
killing with it and to you I say that's
great let's talk on november nine then
it's just so funny when people email me
as if my coverage of the election makes
no sense because it's a hundred percent
written on the wall everything that's
going to happen on november eighth we
know that the odds in the real world and
on Betty si.com are in favor of Hillary
Clinton in the national election but we
also know that we've seen some
tightening in Donald Trump's favor over
the last week or so so if you're super
confident go to bed d si.com they've
been in business for 20 years the mobile
website they have is
rate I hate it when I go to a website on
my phone and it's just a disaster on
your phone it's not at all optimized for
phone Betty si.com is easy to use from
any device and use the code Pakman 25 PA
que ma n 25 you will get a free $25 for
an election play and then let's talk on
November ninth and see who really did
know what was going to happen